he said I have a really funny idea for
the movie what if Mario he gets his
strength from the mushroom but he also
is repelled by it so he thinks they're
disgusting I really wanted to include
this idea that Mario actually doesn't
like mushrooms really him powering up
for the first time he's not actually
afraid of all the hard stuff he has to
do
he's just afraid of eating a mushroom
miyamo's son's playful irony now this
has to be a mushroom we just thought
that was such a funny idea that we could
just pull through the whole movie okay
okay there are two types of flowers the
fire flower
which is represented in a really cool
way actually
it's not like I'm burning my enemies to
death it was just like a field of fire
flowers it's a quieter scene and we used
it in a way that helped tell the story
but it drew from The Well of Nintendo
and we just love that
we got the Ice Flower
and The Stand Out ice
Peach also uses that at the end of the
film to battle Bowser
to a standstill nice and easy